Hi, everyone.
My name is Sam, and
I'm a graduate student
in Comparative Media Studies.
I have a background in animation
and public health research,
and I'm fascinated by people who
can take big, complex history
topics and offer them up for
discussion in artistic formats.
So I'm really excited to
be speaking with Rosa today
for a CAST conversation.
And I'd love to give Rosa a
chance for a self-introduction.
Hi.
I'm Rosa, and I am an
illustrator comic artist
from Puerto Rico.
I live in San Juan.
And I have been self-publishing
comics for 10 years.
And recently I've switched
over to political comics, where
I try to write a comic
about our experiences
in the island, our politics,
and all the problems that
have surfaced after
Hurricane Maria specifically.
And I usually publish
mostly on The Nib,
but I've also been published
on the Believer and The Lily
for The Washington Post.
So my first question
that sort of
brings us here today
is pretty basic,
but what brought you
to MIT, and how is it
influencing your work?
Well, I was invited by
CAST and Michael Jacobson
to work for the MIT Game Lab on
illustrations for a board game
based on PROMESA, the
PROMESA law in Puerto Rico.
So the PROMESA law is a law that
President Obama signed way back
in 2016, and it imposes a
fiscal oversight and control
board over our government.
And it's been a huge-- of course
it's been a huge issue here.
And I wrote a little bit
about it on my comics.
And so Michael
contacted me based
on that because
they wanted somebody
who was native to the
problem and to the country
to do the illustrations
for this board game.
Oh, and I'm also interested in
sort of this shift from some
of the more 2D, static
artistic formats
that you said that
you're rooted in
and how the interactivity
and the collaboration
of this project affects your
approach to covering the topic.
Well, it's been
really interesting
because I've never worked
on a game board before,
and I hardly even
play them, even.
So it was very interesting to
figure out how to tell a story.
I cannot tell right
now if it's just my--
OK, it looks like
Rosa is frozen.
It's not just me.
So while I think we wait
for Rosa to join us,
I think I can use
this time to set up
the next line of
questioning that I have.
Basically I had the
wonderful opportunity
to play test the
PROMESA board game
that the Game Lab is
working on and that Rosa
is contributing to.
And the design of it, to
me, is really fascinating.
It takes this complex story
of the law that Rosa was just
describing and puts you in
the position, maybe generally
the Puerto Rican
government, trying
to make balances
between spending money
on infrastructure and
education and paying off
its debt to the US.
And the debt is sort of in the
form of these physical jewels
that you're trying to
push off of the map.
But in order to
do that, you also
need to spend some
of those jewels
on education, on infrastructure.
Rosa is back.
Cool.
Yes, I'm sorry.
The internet, it's crazy here.
Yeah.
I fixed it, so hopefully
it won't happen again.
All right.
I was talking a little
bit about my experience
play testing the game and just
the way that it kind of works.
I think we can
circle back to some
of the experience
with the medium
as a part of this question.
But I was essentially
sort of talking
about how one thing that stuck
out to me about this game
was how really closely tied
the topic and the format
are compared to other games that
I've had the chance to test out
with the Game lab and their
anti-colonial board game
project, sort of playing
other board games that
approach this topic.
One thing that stuck out to
me about a lot of those games
is that the colonialist
themes usually have nothing
to do with the actual
gameplay or the interactions,
and rather than make some sort
of educational or aesthetic
or emotional statement
about colonialism,
those games usually
just use the theme
as an excuse to have fun
while collecting treasure.
And so it was really refreshing
for me to see this board game
dive into the tricky questions
of how to educate and offer
a meaningful
aesthetic experience
and highlight the emotional
experience of balancing
infrastructure and education and
debt at that government level.
And so my next question
is related to that.
In contributing your
artwork to this game,
I really want to know
what it's like to try
to do all of those
things at once
and have the artwork
also help people
learn how to play the game.
And so I know you got cut
off a little bit in sort
of explaining how the
format affects you,
but I think this can
sort of all be rolled up
into one big question.
Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
Yeah, I mean, Michael
didn't explain to me
how the game was before I got
to MIT for the quick visit,
and I think he was
right because you
have to actually experience it.
Because it's-- I was also kind
of expecting it to be like,
well, I'm going to
educate you about this,
and you're going
to roll the dice,
and you're going to get
from point A to point B,
and that's it.
But I think what they created
is very creative because it puts
the person in the position
of having to actually analyze
on how to spend the
resources of a whole country,
but in a very simple way.
So one of my challenges is how
to contextualize that so it's
even more obvious so that when
the game asks you to invest
in infrastructure, then,
well, what specific example
of Puerto Rico's
history can I use
there so that the person
can engage with history
as well as engage with the game?
And because I do comics,
I'm very used to, well,
I'll walk you through the story.
But now the people actually
have to play the game,
and it's very cooperative,
too, like you noticed.
So what I think
my challenge is is
how to present Puerto Rico
in a non-stereotypical way,
how to contextualize the history
so that the person understands
how to play it, but at the same
time learn something about how,
well, if we put the
resources from education
to infrastructure,
then you lose this,
and this is going to happen.
It could end up in a protest.
It could end up in
a teacher strike.
But also, one of
the things that I'm
very excited to work
on with this project
is that Michael also wanted a
comic book as the instructions.
But then the comic
book is not only
just going to be the
instructions on how to play.
It'll be a conversation between
two players about the context
of the history of the game.
So I'm very excited to
be able to put something
that I'm very comfortable
with into the game
at the same time while
being challenged with all
of the illustrations and kind
of the decisions of what I want
to illustrate there so that
the person takes something
away from the game more than
the enjoyment of playing.
Oh, and I think that leads
me into my final question
of there's a lot to
unpack in this game.
I think it'll mean
a lot depending on
who plays it, in what
context, and when, even.
And so my last question
to you is, who do you
want to play this game?
I want everybody
to play the game,
but I know that everybody
here is super excited.
The moment I said
that I was working
on a board game
about Puerto Rico,
people were like,
but what is it about?
What-- I need to know.
Do you have a prototype?
And they were so excited.
So I would really love
to have, once everything
is done to a point,
I would really
love to have a community--
after the pandemic,
after everything--
a community play so that people
here can add their own stories
to the game and maybe start--
I think this game
can probably have
a type of closure or healing
on some of these topics.
Oh, yeah, like
they could go, oh,
I remember when we
protested about this,
or I remember how I felt when
the government announced this
and that, but they are
also working together
and realize that, oh, yeah,
if we do invest in education,
we might have a way out.
So it sounds like a bit
of a grim game saying,
oh, this is just to push
the debt off the island,
and the debt is so huge
that it's unpayable,
and you're going to learn that.
But I think because
it's cooperative,
it has a way to maybe help form
a conversation so that people
can get a little bit of
closure and a little bit
of recontextualization on their
feelings and of their history.
I'm very excited to play here.
Yeah, I'm excited to play
the final game as well.
Great.
Thanks so much.
This was a really
fantastic conversation.
It was really inspiring to learn
more about your own approach
to this work, how the
dialogue around the project
and your exposure to
some of the issues
that you're talking about,
getting that into MIT
and making that part of the
conversation around here.
It's something that I
really appreciated seeing.
So thank you so much,
and thanks for the--
No, thank everybody for letting
me work on this project.
Thank you, Sam and Rosa.
And thanks, everyone,
for joining us
for this conversation.
Please visit
arts.mit.edu/fromanywhere
for a wide range
of arts activities,
online exhibitions and
performances, research,
and more.
Also, keep an eye on our
website for more information
about this board game and the
developments in the future.
Thanks again, everyone, and
have a wonderful weekend.
Goodbye.
Bye.